a cricket situation so you've got a
quicker ball
um up here attached i assume to a hand i
hope otherwise like some ghost cricket
ball or something
and um glenn glenn the fastballer let's
let's draw a glance shall we
this is the greatest diagram of all time
okay 2.4 yeah that's probably
fancy it's pretty tall anyway
so the picture is
he has the ball and he's about to
release it okay
he um throws about 144 kilometers per
hour which is actually way slower than
he bowls i think they just do that to
make the numbers neat um he's close to
like 150 plus actually well he's
questioning zero now because he's
retired but anyway
and he throws it down at um a seven
degree angle of depression okay so you
can see it there off the tangent
so uh what's being asked a few things
okay so firstly we're asked to prove
some equations for i think for x dot no
for x and for y okay so as usual with
all projectile motion questions we start
with
acceleration okay so
horizontal acceleration as you know it's
zero
and we have to build from here by
integration all the way up to the x
function okay now
it's unfortunately a little bit
laborious you really must include all
four constants because you integrate
four times okay please don't do
shortcuts there
be regression the way that you do it so
i actually write just to remind myself
to actually put the constants in that x
dot is the integral of x double dot with
respect to time okay that's an
unnecessary step it really is but i put
an interest for myself
so since it's just um zero right it's
going to be a constant
and if i'm going to evaluate that
constant i'm going to need to know okay
what is the initial
motion over time okay so therefore this
is where you start to bring in your
rectangle okay so it's going downwards
right so i'm going to draw it sort of
like this
okay i've got 144
kilometers per hour but they ask for the
resultant equations in meters per second
okay so just watch for that therefore
i'm going to have to convert
144 kilometers per hour is
144 000
meters
per 3 600 seconds right so that's just
my conversion okay once you divide
through i think you get 40.
okay
now what else have i got here this is um
seven degrees that's my alpha my initial
angle okay
and so because i'm thinking about
horizontal vertical right x dot
you can this is part this part you can
quote
x is v cos alpha right because alpha so
there's my v
40
and my f is seven right so 40 cos
seven
while i'm at it on the diagram i might
as well do y dot
and it's only different by um the
function so it's going to be 40 sine 7.
at least it's almost 47. what i miss
it's got to be negative okay please
watch out for your science i mean the
fact that i've drawn this diagram
downwards or to clear you in okay but um
it's it's decreasing okay it's going
closer towards the origin uh the ground
rather
okay so when t equals zero
exponents equal to this actually when t
is anything you like x dot is equal to
this because horizontal velocity is a
constant
so therefore i can say
c1 is going to be equal to
that constant okay so here's my
acceleration for any value of time
integrate another time
and you slap your t in there
plus your second constant
now we're starting at zero okay so
therefore this constant as it usually
does turns out to be zero because it's a
bit silly to sort of define your
starting point as something non-zero
okay so c2 is equal to zero
therefore
here's the first
step that you get uh first result rather
that you get asked to show is that right
on the question 12 yeah does that look
great
thumbs up
okay
all right move on to y dot okay so sorry
why actually rely enough room not quite
but i'll try and squeeze in start from
acceleration
and i think they specify 10 for gravity
so we've got -10 here so integrating
once
i'm going to get minus 10 t plus my
constant okay
there's my value for what uh
y dot is equal to initially right so
when t equals 0
y dot is equal to v sine
alpha
okay so therefore
40
sine
seven is equal to zero plus
okay sorry minus minus
caught myself okay so therefore y dot
minus 10 t
minus
40 sine
7.
okay
integrate again to get up to the
displacement function at least for y
anyway so y is the integral of y is not
dt
so minus 10 t turns into the familiar
minus five t squared
minus
40 t sine
7
plus my constant
sorry i called this constant one that's
a bit naughty isn't it i think that's up
to three
and here's constant four
now here's where the question gets it
wrong they call this point the origin
but quite obviously it's not the origin
okay so therefore when t equals 0
according to this diagram
y is 2.4 now by the way we couldn't just
as easily have defined this as the
origin and later on when we're trying to
work out this spot it would be
minus 2.4 it doesn't matter okay
here we're going to have
y be equal to 2.4
so
2.4 is equal to
minus
zero squared
okay so
there is my uh c4 right
that's the value i'm actually going to
slap in so therefore
my actual displacement function is minus
5t squared
minus that
plus my constant was that what i wanted
to show
happy so far right now